yang speaks is sponsored by expressvpn
protect your online privacy today at
expressvpn.com
yang
[Music]
[Applause]
the democratic party needs to not
content itself with being
the party of the urban core
whatever you want to say about trump and
there's a lot to say when he ran
one thing he did i will give him credit
for is he looked at these people
in blue collar small towns and he said
you know what your lives are important
your problems exist and i'm going to
help them now he hasn't helped him and
he's full of it and he doesn't care
about him
but at least he acknowledged them and we
in the democratic party
do not acknowledge them way too often i
don't think it's out of maliciousness i
just don't think there are very many
democrats who know about places like
this i mean there are not too many
shared browns and so you don't hear
voices like mine when's the last time
you heard outside of james carville a
southern
twang representing the democratic party
and i'm
living proof that if you speak to folks
they will listen
because no one's going to mistake me for
like someone uh you know who i mean
maybe they would
like i'd appreciate it you have
you come off as someone who genuinely
cares and most importantly you don't
come off as someone
who thinks they're better a lot of
this is in places like kentucky we are
worried that you and the rest of the
country look down at us
we are worried that you think we're
stupid that you think we don't
know how to do anything and when someone
talks to us like that
we turn them off they're done forget it
i am thrilled to welcome the yang speaks
uh someone who's a force of media nature
in his
own right matt jones the founder of
kentucky sports radio
new york times best-selling author of
the book mitch please
about mitch mcconnell and his native
kentucky
graduate of duke university and
transylvania university which i
i confess i did have to look up
well welcome i went to law school duke i
i
i have to take up for my transylvania
oldest university west of the allegheny
mountains but i went to law school at
duke
i have to say matt you are living the
dream of so many law school graduates i
know
in that you went to law school and now
you are
a sports radio host talking about
politics and things that people care
about you're hugely popular
in kentucky and as someone who graduated
from law school
uh i there are so many lawyers i wish
they had your gig let's put it that way
[Laughter]
well you know i i actually i never
thought i would do sports and it just
kind of came about in the mid
2000s when sort of blogs were becoming a
big thing which there's a lot of people
listening to your podcast you don't know
what blogs are because
people don't use them anymore but in the
mid 2000s that was a real thing and i
started a kentucky blog and it kind of
it was good timing and it kind of took
off uh and i got to get out of the legal
profession which anybody who's in the
law
you get really excited to do it and then
you try your best to get out of it as
quickly as possible and that guy that
happened for me and i got to pursue
something i really loved uh but then
sort of
found my way back to doing political
stuff in the last few years so it's been
a weird career
all kind of bouncing back and forth we
had a good laugh where i'm wearing a
t-shirt uh for you and you're wearing a
button-down for me
uh you know we're both just being good
andrew i wear a
hoodie every day like i have like 75
hoodies from 75 sports teams
and today on the radio i talked about
i'm going on the andrew yang podcast i
think i'm about to put a dress shirt on
for like the first time in a year and a
half
and then i come out here and you're
wearing a t-shirt
yeah um well i appreciate you looking
out for me because we have a very
buttoned up crowd
uh here in the yangyang and yang speaks
like they definitely would have
appreciated the extra effort on your
part yeah i'm
thrilled to talk to you about what
your perspective is on what the heck we
are doing wrong
in places like kentucky uh so right now
you have mitch mcconnell
uh in some quarters a deeply unpopular
man
[Laughter]
well not just in some quarters deeply
unpopular in kentucky and i think that's
misunderstood nationally but definitely
deeply unpopular
not just you know in big cities or in
the democratic party but
in his state he is extremely disliked
so let's dig into this because this is a
very is a very important misconception
that a lot of people might have
so i'm just going to speak for myself
outside looking in
uh mitch mcconnell seems like a a very
uh dc oriented guy he's been there
forever
uh he he seems eminently unlikable
uh and the impression is that somehow he
has like this
uh mind control over the people of
kentucky
where like everyone everyone's like oh
mitch she's like
somehow an institution that's what it
looks like from the outside looking in
where you
you think uh that like
of course i find him very unlikable but
like you just said that that
um apparently that's not unique to
people outside of kentucky
yeah one of the things i always get very
frustrated about when i talk to people
from outside
of kentucky is they act like and
especially to be honest with you
democrats our side
they act like we're a bunch of idiots a
bunch of dupes who don't understand how
bad mitch mcconnell
is and gosh these stupid people in
kentucky that's not what it is
i mean for my book i went to every
county in kentucky we have 120 which is
too many but we have 120
and i went to every one and finding a
true mitch mcconnell supporter is almost
impossible
nobody likes the guy and nobody likes
him for the exact reason you said
they don't feel like he cares about
kentucky they feel like he's a dc
person but here's the problem we've
never as democrats given them somebody
who people believe cares more than mitch
in kentucky and i think in a lot of red
states if you have a
run-of-the-mill republican and a running
mill democrat
people are going to vote for the
republican they just are so you have to
do something different and you have to
say
i am different than them in a way that
connects and the problem for the
democratic party in my opinion
in middle america especially is that we
connect culturally but we don't connect
economically and in places where the
culture is not the same as a lot of the
mainstream parts of the democratic party
they just have no connection to the
democratic party
so we have stopped talking about blue
collar issues or we don't do it enough
and that is how you used to win in
kentucky democrats used to run this
state forever
and they talked about blue collar this
is a working-class state this used to be
a big union state
and when does last time you've heard a
democrat talk about unions man don't
talk about unions they don't
ever and they coal mining unions were
huge here steel unions like they
look you know this was a union place and
people just don't ever bring it up
and thus since the culture wars become a
lot of national politics it hurts in
places like here and that is why
mitch mcconnell who is deeply unliked
who workers believe doesn't care about
them at all
when it becomes a culture war battle
they end up choosing his side
your point about how democrats have lost
on the economic messaging
and for blue-collar workers union
households i experienced the same thing
on the trail
and one of the things that they're
seeing right now between
joe and trump is that a lot of the union
leaders are endorsing joe and kamala
because you still have like a democratic
relationship there
but a lot of the rank and file members
are voting for trump and that
happened at a very high level
in 2016 where like the majority of these
union households went to trump no matter
what their leaders said
and that's going to keep happening if
we're not careful i think the difference
in my opinion the reason in michigan
pennsylvania and wisconsin biden is
doing
a little better than clinton is that
that kind of rank and file union like
joe a little bit better than they like
hillary and he talked a little bit more
about this stuff but that's where we're
losing you know i speak to union groups
all the time and what my message is
welcome
in those in those places but they don't
hear democrat
politicians talking about that certainly
on the national level now on the state
level we have a democratic governor
again andy beshear
and a big part of that was because he
spoke to teachers unions
and and that was a big part of him
getting elected
i think we've lost that message and part
of the reason i really liked you
i ended up endorsing you which i had no
intention of doing when i saw you
thank you appreciate it yeah thank you
and you got up and said so you got up
and told so i took my radio show to iowa
it's a sports radio show but i wanted to
do something
different so i took them to the iowa
caucuses and we saw
every candidate speak and the three guys
who do the show with me don't even care
about
politics and i was interested to see
what happens at the end of this
who will they be for and everyone on our
show was for you
at the end and the reason was when we
saw you speak you talked about the
economic
impact on small towns we saw you in a
place called perry iowa
and you got up and said look no one
speaks about economics in small towns
and you're right republicans don't now
they'll speak about
culture and social issues but they don't
talk about the economics because it's
their economic policy that's killing
small towns
and democrats act like those places
don't even exist and when you
you spoke about it and you're right
america is full of small towns and most
people live in cities started in small
towns
and we're just abandoning them
abandoning them and then and i don't
know
unless we figure that out we're gonna
have a place
where you know there's gonna be vast
swaths of land where people are just
isolated from the economy and you know
dollar general stores started in
kentucky and i wrote about this in mitch
please
how they go into small towns and
basically ruin the communities they
close all the local stores
they create the only place people shop
and the next thing you know
all the money gets shipped out that's
what i worry about across the united
states
that's a hundred percent happening right
now and you can see
dollar general and walmart came and ran
over the mom and pops
uh and then now amazon's like a
spaceship that's like sucking up
what whatever is left uh and if you're
in the small town it's not just that
you're isolated
like when your way of life starts to
degrade then terrible things start
happening you look around like you know
you have
people who are still living there and as
the opportunities dry up
um you have people drink more people
end up with domestic violence and
other problems at higher levels or they
never marry they they never
find a partner because getting married
having a child they're very optimistic
acts
like you you you need a degree of
stability if you're going to get
together with someone and say hey
let's get married let's start a family
let's do all the stuff um
and you start kicking out the paths
forward for a lot of people
you see families deteriorate very
quickly or never form
i'm with you that this is the disconnect
for the democratic party
like the democratic party needs to not
content itself with being
uh the party of the urban core
or of cultural issues i i there was part
of me matt when i was running
i was like is there some kind of strange
agenda where people
prefer it if we talk about these
cultural issues
over the the uh bread and butter the
dollars and cents because they're just
making a lot of money off us they just
want to
pit us against each other on this
[ __ ] and
all the way to the bank i mean if you
were to go on fox news or msnbc and try
to argue about tax policy
you know i mean who nobody's gonna care
but it is what's most important i mean
so i live in kentucky people still like
trump here at least a lot of people do
and i will talk to them they'll say why
don't you like him and and there are
a million reasons but the thing that
bothers me the most were his tax cuts
he basically enacted mitch mcconnell's
tax policy
which has a hugely detrimental impact on
the poor
and the middle class vis-a-vis the
wealthy and people just
and and it happened and everybody got
excited because they got you know a
check in the mail for
for one time and it infuriates me
because
whatever you want to say about trump and
there's a lot to say when he ran
one thing he did i will give him credit
for is he looked at these people
in blue collar small towns and he said
you know what your lives are important
your problems exist and i'm going to
help him now he hasn't helped him and
he's full of it he doesn't care about
him
but at least he acknowledged them and we
in the democratic party
do not acknowledge them way too often i
don't think it's out of maliciousness
i just don't think there are very many
democrats who know about places like
this i mean there are not too many
shared browns there just aren't too many
of those people
left that are winning elections and so
you don't hear
voices like mine when's the last time
you heard outside of james carville
a southern twang representing the
democratic party
i don't know i mean it just does not
happen and i think that leads to a lot
of people
you know colin powell said many years
ago about african americans until they
can see
people represented that look like them
in the republican party they're not
going to join it
and he was right well what's happening
is in small towns they're not seeing
people like them
representing the democratic party and
it's turning them off
and i'm living proof that if you speak
to folks they will listen because no
one's going to mistake me for
like like someone uh you know who i mean
maybe they would
like i'd appreciate you have
you come off as someone who genuinely
cares and most importantly you don't
come off as someone
who thinks they're better a lot of this
is in places like kentucky we are
worried
that you and the rest of the country
look down at us we are worried that you
think we're stupid
that you think we don't know how to do
anything and when someone talks to us
like that
we turn them off they're done forget it
and i'm not going to call out the
politicians that do
that but there are a lot that do you
don't do that
i don't think joe biden does that and i
actually think that's why
you've seen him do better than some
other candidates
is simply that notice when the
democratic primaries got to the states
that are like that joe won in a
heartbeat and i think you would have had
success for that same reason you're the
only two candidates in the election that
i genuinely thought
spoke to people in places like this in a
way they could connect
i'm so glad that that people sensed that
i was for
them uh and i certainly don't think i'm
uh better than
than anybody uh you know i mean i'm
fighting for the the folks in kentucky
and around the country that
just look up and say what the heck
happened to our
country like why does it seem like it
it's uh
getting run for anyone but us at this
point so
i'm grateful that folks saw that
[Music]
you know yang speaks we think that your
data
should be yours we have prop 24 on the
ballot in california coming up
but there are things you can do right
now to protect your data and one thing
we recommend
is use a virtual private network which
lets you beam into the internet from
anywhere no one can track
your activity including your isp which
right now
often is keeping track of everything you
do expressvpn
is the vpn that we recommend it's not
just us
also wired recommends them the verge
recommends them
expressvpn is best of breed for
consumers
who want your online activity to remain
yours and yours alone
go to expressvpn.com yang to get an
extra three months of expressvpn for
free
expressvpn.com yang
take your data back or at least make it
so that it's not
the data broker's data too if you know
what i mean
[Music]
[Applause]
so the democratic party to me and this
is one of the things that it's
fascinating about your story
so you are one of the most prominent
progressives in the state of kentucky
uh you've identified the real issues
that people care about people will
listen to you because they they sense
that
you're a different voice and the
democrats not being
complete morons were like hey we should
try and recruit him
we should recruit this guy to run for
office and you get asked about it every
single cycle
which makes sense because you would be
one of the most successful prospects
that
they could possibly field and you went
so far as to attend a
one of those congressional candidate uh
training camps
um and after you went through that you
said you know what i'm not sure i'm
going to
run run that cycle i think it was 16
when they were
talking to you uh so tell us about
why you took a hard look
uh and what your experience was
well so i do a radio show every day and
i would argue i'm probably
one of the only people in the country
who is a progressive and an
outspoken progressive that speaks to a
conservative audience every day
seventy percent seventy five percent of
my audience are trump voters
and that's because that's the sports
audience in kentucky and they know i'm a
progressive but they're okay
with me because they think i think they
think my heart is in the right place
so in 2016 they called me up to consider
running against andy barr
in the congressional district that
represents lexington kentucky
and long story short they asked me to
come to this congressional boot camp
where they teach people how to run
and i went there and i was with the 50
to 60 candidates that were in the swing
districts that you had to win the sort
of purple districts
and it included a lot of names of people
that you would know
and they basically did a three-day camp
on how you went
and it was the most depressing thing i
have ever been a part of because my
theory
my thought was okay they're going to
teach you how to campaign how to talk
about issues
they're going to talk about you know
what would what's a good policy to have
on this or that
none of that was a conversation no one
andrew
even asked me what i believed on
anything ever
i mean they just thought well you could
win
so you should come and run i could have
believed any
anything in the world and they wouldn't
have known they didn't care
they just thought i could win and at the
boot camp all they taught you
literally all they taught you was how to
raise money the whole thing was about
money
a very prominent congress person stood
up and said
let me tell you what doesn't matter
meeting with voters doesn't matter
your policies don't matter what matter
is what matters is
how much money can you raise and how do
you utilize it
and when i heard her say that i knew i
wasn't gonna run because i was like i'm
not gonna do this this is such a
terrible
part of potentially being in office and
in congress especially in the house
you have such little power that they
just see you as a number
to get to a majority and i came home and
i almost said you know what i'm done
with politics period it was that
depressing now i didn't do that
but it really showed me and i'm sure the
republicans have the same thing
it really showed me that at least at
that level it's not about issues
it's not about anything except raising
money and getting the vote to get a
majority
i'm the numbers guy madden they probably
told you this at the boot camp
but the average successful congressional
candidate raises
and spends 1.6 million dollars on their
campaign so you have to ask yourself
okay
who the heck can raise 1.6 million
dollars for a congressional campaign
but that's the reason they think the way
they do they're just like well let's say
you're a great human being you have
great vision
you know people really connect with you
but can you get 1.6 million dollars
uh and if not then none of your personal
qualities will care
they become very uh
very mechanical do you believe that i
mean do you believe that because i don't
do you believe that do i believe that
that the average
congressional candidate that succeeds
raises 1.6 million
let's let's talk about what happened
here in kentucky during the senate
primary
a guy named charles booker who i
endorsed and really liked a lot
nearly pulled off one of the most
shocking primary upsets ever
against amy mcgrath amy mcgrath raised
she's raised like 50 million dollars for
this senate campaign
at one point charles booker had like 30
dollars in the bank
and booker got the spark mostly via
social media
and the money came after and i'm sort of
of the belief now you need a base money
or at least a base
presence or a social media something
but the money for charles he would have
if he had gotten the nomination he'd had
all the money he needed against mitch
mcconnell anybody
heck yes yeah but he
basically just once he got the spark and
people knew who he was
he raised a lot of money and if he had
had one more week left in the election
he would have been the nominee and done
very well i think against mcconnell may
not have beaten him but he'd been close
i don't agree that it should be about
who can have the most money because i
think
steve bannon who i think is a contempt
contemptible person
but he said one thing i think is right
which is i actually think argue
art weirdly money almost matters less
now because there are so many ways to
get it
and when you get to big races you'll get
it anyway
because people will want you to win so i
i don't know that i totally agree with
that that like you gotta have that 1.6
million or why even do it
i agree with your disagreeing uh and
charles is a great example
candidates matter candidates matter a
great deal uh you know
it's it's it's one of the things that uh
prompted me to run was i thought you
know what like i
i think that this message needs to get
out there and i think people will
connect with it
and i believe i'll get the resources i
need and i could have lived with myself
if i hadn't you know what i mean it's
not
you know it's not like you could look at
it say you can't know
that's one of the things about these
races too and you hit the nail on the
head with charles like
like if charles puts himself out there
then he has a chance to get the
resources he needs
you know it's like can you know that
someone ahead of time is going to get
the resources
sure in some cases if they're just
sitting on a giant pile of money
but the vast majority of candidates are
going to have to put themselves out
there and hope that they catch that
spark
and then when they do catch that spark
then magical things can happen
and those are the things that make the
dc establishment
look up and be like oh i did not see
that coming
[Music]
when i was running for president one
thing i did was drink
a lot of water green tea
more water and now people are coming up
with better ways to
keep yourself hydrated one of the
innovators in this space is liquid iv
it's the fastest most efficient way to
stay hydrated i'm
32 years old if i have a drink of
alcohol i have them hung over liquid iv
freaking works swear to god i would just
pout i just pound one before i go to bed
throw it in a glass of water
you have a serving and it's as much
hydration as two to three bottles of
water how the heck does that work
liquid iv is available everywhere but
you can get 25
off when you go to liquidive.com and use
the code yang
at checkout that's 25 off anything you
order
if you use the promo code yang at
liquidiv.com
get better hydration today at
liquidive.com
promo code yang and you'll thank us
because you'll feel
like your body's getting what it needs
[Music]
uh so amy mcgrath i believe had
tens of millions of dollars for the
primary she was already spending money
on tv ads and the rest of it
no one expected charles to challenge her
seriously and then it became very
serious
where he almost took the nomination
and she squeaked it out and then now
charles and everyone's behind her
because you got to try and beat mitch
but it seems like she is not
as close as you'd hope uh last thing i
saw had her down like nine or ten points
so why is it that people in kentucky are
not excited about amy
and i you know i don't want to put words
in anyone's mouth but you know like i
don't know if you agree with
the fact that people aren't excited i i
don't know i i don't want to be
negative towards amy because i think she
is a good person but
i she's going to lose by 20. i i i i i
really believe that 15 to 20.
in mitch please i wrote about i actually
was
thinking about that race seriously i
mean not just kind of thinking about it
i
i went into it i did polling i put my
own personal money into looking at it
and i detail pretty you know
specifically how it is that candidates
end up not running and this is no
offense to amy mcgrath but
my race is an example so i was
considering running and chuck schumer
and the dscc decided amy mcgrath's going
to be our candidate
and what that was meaning was i could
not
even get people andrew to work for me
there are nine polling uh democratic
polling sources and none of them would
take me
because the dscc told them if you work
for him
you can't work for any of our candidates
i couldn't find
anyone to even help me the only people
that would help me were these sort of
rogue progressives who were very nice
but also didn't want me to tell anybody
they were working for me because they
were worried
that schumer and those people would get
mad at him schumer basically put
a if you help him and now when i say
schumer it was the dscc
specifically if you work for him
you can't do anything for us so there
was a major democratic party donor here
in kentucky and one of the biggest
national donors who like who thought i
was the best candidate
and basically went to schumer and said
look you got to give this guy a chance
and
only because of that did he agree to me
with me and i talked specifically about
what happened in that meeting
it was a fine meeting he brought me up i
spent a couple hours with him
he agreed to finally like take his hand
off the button and let me
recruit people but he told me flat out
i don't think anybody can beat mitch
mcconnell we're for amy mcgrath because
we know she can raise money
and it will keep mitch distracted that's
he told me that
flat out and i said i think you're wrong
someone can beat him
and he said well if you want to try go
for it but
their whole thing was just to get
someone who could raise money and they
knew that amy mcgrath was a
money-raising machine
they just gave up on kentucky before it
even started
and it was infuriating i ended up not
doing it but i have to tell you andrew i
almost did it just to just to prove them
wrong you know
but charles is a perfect example charles
and there's polling private polling that
suggests this
charles would have made this a much
closer race but chuck schumer didn't
care about it being a close race
he cared about the money being raised
and that's the problem
that is very tough to hear because there
are so many missed opportunities
really amy's background
um i mean she obviously has a very
impressive personal
and military background and she'd raised
a ton of money in an
earlier race um so what were those the
reasons why
chuck looked up or the dscc looked up
and said okay
um we're going to get behind amy because
she'd
she like how much did she raise in her
previous race
well on paper she's a perfect candidate
military veteran
uh very smart engaging et cetera
but races are not run on paper she
raised a lot of money in 2018
in a midterm partially because she put
out one of the best television
commercials you'll ever see which was
her first commercial
which went viral and she raised a ton of
money but i think this is important
she lost and she lost when the polls
said
that she was going to win she way
underperformed expectations
but it was like nobody even cared they
just sort of moved
past that and said well you know still
she's the best candidate
i think what you get is when you have
people from washington d.c
saying what they believe people in
kentucky will like
they're going to screw it up i mean what
do they know they're not in kentucky
if you had been here in 2018 and i say
this with no
offense to amy mcgrath who i think is
you know a good person and
and a military hero
but if you had been here in 2018 you
would know that she could not beat mitch
mcconnell
and that putting her in the race in
kentucky was a terrible mistake you
would just know that
but i don't think anybody in kentucky
was ever even consulted
the question was just who did who did
chuck schumer want
and when chuck schumer wanted them they
win and i think there are other examples
around the country of that it is very
difficult in a primary to beat the
establishment
pick so and then the field gets weighted
because she raised so much money she
raised like
eight million dollars her first two
weeks in the campaign
andrew how am i supposed to compete in a
primary against somebody has
eight million dollars when where and
then when they tell big donors don't
give him money where am i supposed to
get any money
you know charles booker if it was not
for the black lives matter protest he
may have never even gotten
sort of noticed but he did because he
was such a great leader during that time
period
but before that she just had so much
money
it was impossible and that was all done
by the national party
and this is a missed opportunity i'm not
gonna lie it would have been hard to
beat mitch mcconnell would not have been
easy you would have had to run a
perfect race especially with trump on
the ballot if he wasn't on the ballot
it's different but
but it was possible and
they picked a candidate that made it
impossible and i think and i
i don't say this hopeful because i'm
going to vote for her and i hope she
wins
i think she will lose by an amount that
will really surprise people
this is really the difference between
making a calculation based on numbers
and humanity where if you are at some
dashboard in dc and you look up
uh and you think okay this is a race
where
uh we don't expect to win because we
haven't been competitive in that area so
i'm going to make a resource decision uh
and what
comes to mind for me is sometimes what
you want to do is you want
to make a more high variance human
decision which is like
okay this person uh there's a great
chance that they
never get lift off and they they lose
terribly but there's at least
some upside here where like i can
project that they
actually inspire people and lead people
in in a tremendous way
and you can get a sense of that from
spending time
with someone like if you have a
particular lens
like i i've spoken to charles multiple
times and at length
and it does not take that long to think
wow this is like a really great
human being like he you know he has like
the makings of of a
real leader that would galvanize people
i've spoken to you now
during this period and we met in iowa
and i remember that
and given who you are in your audience
uh
and the fact that you communicate for a
living uh and you understand the
community
and you've got a background that a lot
of people respect and you care about
things that other people care about and
you know like the rest of you can
connect with people on multiple levels
um you are a tremendous upside pick uh
you know like the fact that at least
they were talking to you about it means
that
again they're not um totally
um with their heads in the sand but
that's the kind of thing you would do is
you would choose like high variance
humans and say okay like this person
has a chance to uh take off in a way
that
would inspire people that that would be
the the other way of doing it as opposed
to
looking at it as numbers on a ledger
i like everything you said there i'll
give you an analogy for sports
because that's what i do most of the
time so the sec is the best for football
and many years ago kentucky had been
terrible at football for like 30
straight years and cm newton the
athletic director said
we can keep trying to do it the same way
and hire the same coaches they do but we
never win
we used to we hired alabama's former
coach and he lost
terribly because we're not alabama so he
decided let me try something completely
different so he went and hired a
division two coach named hal
mummy from valdosta georgia who came up
here and decided i'm gonna do things
completely different i'm gonna throw
every pass we're not gonna run the ball
we're just gonna
air it out he created something called
the air raid came to kentucky
and they won a lot of games here and
that offense that he created
is now the most popular offense in
college football mike leach has had
success with it there are guys in the
nfl using it
it started at kentucky because they
didn't think they had any chance and
they wanted to try something crazy
different to see if it would work
that's exactly what you're talking about
i mean kentucky in senate races
is about like kentuckian football was
back then which is a long shot
and why wouldn't you try something
different i mean
what's better spend 50 million dollars
and lose by 12
or try something different maybe lose by
30 or maybe pull off an upset and i
would argue it's a lot better to do the
latter
i think the national party sees the
former as better because it's safer
and parties don't like to take take
chances and the republican party by the
way is better at this than us
because starting really with the tea
party they've kind of said you know what
primaries have at it and whoever comes
out will support them
we don't do that and i think sometimes
that leads to
candidates that just don't inspire
anyone
i can relate to this from my experience
as a presidential candidate where i went
around and i was
uh running and the more dc
you were the less you thought that i had
any business running
[Laughter]
really and then um
as i would outperform dc candidates we
we were joking
that like it's all fun and games until
andrew gang passes you in the polls
uh and i became like the grim reaper of
candidates where as soon as i passed you
then like bad things started happening
to your campaign
um so so that that was the the
conventional wisdom being
thrown on its ear in the same way you're
describing it's like you know
you you look at some of these sports
programs like oh
try something different like andrew yang
was definitely something different uh
and there were a lot of people that were
surprised by
by our relative success
[Music]
[Applause]
this episode of yank speaks is brought
to you by freshly one of the
biggest indicators of how you're going
to feel is really what you're putting in
your body
and if you're like me maybe you're not
the best in the kitchen freshly will
make you feel like you're awesome in the
kitchen because they do most of the work
for you they send it to you
you know you prepare the meal pretty
quickly gives you a sense of
accomplishment and you also get a sense
of accomplishment when you eat the food
because the food is good for you and you
can feel that
so you can take what right now can be
frankly like
oh what am i going to eat like
experience which a lot of us have
during this time and then you go and
then you prepare something that
does not make you feel good about
yourself either in the preparation or in
the eating
you could like turn that experience
around pretty quick
uh we recommend it heartily the the
entire team's been using freshly
and it's been one reason why we're
feeling good so freshly is offering our
listeners 40
off of the first two orders at
freshly.com
yang that's a pretty good deal that's
freshly.com
yang join almost one and a half million
customers
who say that this is a better way to get
your meal going than whatever you're
doing right now
amen yo eat the eat the brisket it's
it's worth it
you'll thank me later freshly.com yang
[Applause]
we succeeded in part because folks
are fed up they're looking around and
saying
business as usual is not working
certainly politics as usual is not
working
uh and i would love to talk to you about
what we can do to build a better
democratic party
uh or whether you think that there is a
third party that's necessary
uh or if if the democratic party is just
not um
like not connecting with people in the
right way and i want to segue into this
with
um with a book called the righteous mind
have you read this book by jonathan hate
i don't think so no it it's okay if you
haven't but i think you would love it
matt because it's right up your alley
um so he identifies six pillars of
morality essentially that make us tick
as human beings
uh even across cultures and
civilizations and he said
he said that uh democrats are good at
arguing about three of them
and republicans are good at arguing
about all six
uh and so that there are certain people
that just don't feel like democrats are
talking to them and
we're having a hard time connecting um
and so this sounds interesting to
to you like i highly recommend it he's a
very very smart guy he's a
professor at nyu but the six pillars and
i might get this wrong
are caring
fairness liberty
authority loyalty
and sanctity and the democrats are good
on the first three they'll they'll argue
for
caring and be like oh how can you do
this terrible thing and like you know
like people
people matter and people are people
and fairness saying like oh you know
these people are not being treated right
uh liberty it gets interpreted
differently but it's like liberty versus
oppression
um and so that there are ways that
democrats argue for
liberty from let's call it you know lack
of health care or something along those
lines
um but then on the the
fourth fifth and sixth uh loyalty
authority and sanctity the democrats
just don't touch him really
look up and be like well those aren't
things that but it turns out that a lot
of human beings
uh and a lot of republicans also care
about
authority loyalty and sanctity uh and
and so you end up with different
cultural conversations taking place
and the the trap for democrats in my
mind is that
they act like well if you don't get the
message then that's your fault like
there's something wrong with you because
there's nothing wrong with our message
our message is great
[Laughter]
i haven't read the book but i totally
see that point
i i always make a joke there's nothing
worse than being in a meeting with a
group of liberals because nobody likes
to take charge because they don't want
to ever say someone
is you know on a higher plane than
somebody else that's kind of the
authority thing
but it's true and i there is a
i think there is a real problem not just
with looking at things differently but
like what you just said andrew which is
i think too many democrats think if you
don't look at these issues the way i do
you're a worse person and a perfect
example is just talking about
trump's supporters in general there's a
lot of people that are democrats that
believe if you support trump you're a
bad person
period they don't want to hear anything
else and i say all the time i understand
why people support trump
i disagree with them but i understand it
i i get what drives them and i don't
think they're bad
because of that as a matter of fact some
of what they that leads them to believe
it
i agree with i just don't agree with
projecting it onto trump
religion i think is where democrats
really screw up
i mean we're very we are good as
democrats in protecting freedom of
religion
for oppressed or minority religions
we're good at that
but we don't like to talk about the
majority religion we don't like to talk
about christianity we just don't like
talk about it i mean people
feel weird talking about it they almost
feel like
that it's it it's not even worth
acknowledging a lot of
i find it strange some politicians won't
joe biden talks about his catholicism
but a lot of
you know i just a lot of politicians
don't seem like they want to talk about
it
religion is at the core part of a lot of
small town life
when i was a kid i didn't know anybody
that didn't go to church
and i feel like we look at that too many
of us look at it not in a negative way
but just in a
that's just not something that should be
part of public discourse
when for many religious people it's the
core feature of their life
sanctity yeah the democrats don't like
to talk about sanctity
it's how they look at everything george
w bush and this was very smart but i
also think this is how he was
he would in speeches put lines from
hymns and bible verses just
put them in he wouldn't say this is from
romans or this is from
you know victory and jesus he would just
put him in and everybody listening
who was a christian was like oh i know
that see he's with us
and but most democrats probably didn't
even know what it happened
you know and i i always really respected
that because he was
it wasn't like some secret code it was
this is a
part of who i am it comes through in
everything i do
i'm a very religious person okay my
religion leads me to believe
we should treat those less fortunate
fortunate than us
with respect dignity and help them it's
why i'm a democrat
and when i say that the reason i'm a
democrat is because i am religious
a lot of people just don't get that even
republicans don't get it
but to me it's a core feature of who i
am and i agree with you that sometimes
it feels like
on the left we don't want to talk about
how
these things like and i'm using the
example of religion can be a core
feature because
it's just not something we're
comfortable with discussing
yeah um there's something so important
in what you just described about
uh the a religiosity of a lot of
democratic
um uh communication uh
and there there's so many things to me
that just american sharon common
i confess when i was running it was so
interesting matt like i'd show up and i
would just
talk the way i talk uh and use the words
i
i used and and people sensed that it was
a different conversation than was being
had because just like there is kind of a
republican
or religious set of cues or code words
like there were a set of democratic and
liberal code words
and i would get up there and i'd give a
talk and i wasn't using the code words
and so people weren't sure when to
applaud
that's like a whole punch list it's like
we're gonna fight for this and i was
like yay we're gonna fight for that yeah
and i was just like huh like i didn't
say any of that uh because
you know it it wasn't uh
it was it you know it wasn't something
that i'd rehearsed or planned
uh and i and so we ended up reaching
different sets of people and having a
different conversation
all of this was accidental by the way
like none of this was planned i just
would show up to an event and be like
hey
here's my here's like here's my
my talk here's my stump speech
so what can we do to either help
overhaul the democratic
party's openness uh to some of these
modes of
communications and values that they
aren't talking about
um or and uh you know that and i raised
it before it's like do you think that
third party is either necessary or
helpful uh if the democratic party
um does not shift or evolve in some way
on the way it talks to people
i'm always skeptical about third parties
because too often third parties just
become a hodgepodge of people who don't
agree on anything
except there just needs to be a third
party and you end up with like
sort of just craziness i mean if there
was
i think for there ever to be a third
party it probably has to be based around
an
individual as bad as that sounds but i
think it probably does
who puts forth a set of ideals and says
i'm stepping away and then people
gravitate
to them but that's going to have to be a
really popular person to do that and i
don't know who could do that
but to your first question about how do
you fix it
you know there were pictures there are
pictures sometimes from the trump
administration where
he'll have like his cabinet or his
advisors and you'll look and it will be
a room full of white men
you know there'll be 50 people in it and
it's 47 white men and i think to myself
how in the world can you believe you can
govern america
when the only people you're hearing from
are white men like that's absolute
insanity
but i also think on the democratic side
sometimes we are well we are very good
at inclusion of many different types of
people
whether it be ethnic religious whatever
but we forget
just thinking differences like just the
way you think about things that is not
based on a demographic
choice but just yes just on a on a way
you look at the world
and there's not an acceptance of a
certain form of diversity
uh yeah i mean there's like there's one
form of diversity no it's not racial
uh you know so that this is me going to
the book again
which now i'm like i'm really like you
know beating it very
very hard uh but one of the things that
uh jonathan hates research
indicates is that that there are some
genetic traits we have that actually
correspond to political orientation
um so he identifies two one is appetite
for novelty like do you just like new
stuff
yeah and two is something called a
disgust reflex which is if i show you
like some you know something gross like
you know garbage or like you know
like the rest of it like do you react
adversely
and these two things actually are
genetic like you know you're sort of
born with with like an appetite for
novelty or disgust reflex
at a certain level and then um they
actually
correspond also to to whether you're
conservative or not like it turns out if
you have
a very uh like high appetite for novelty
then you tend to be more liberal and if
you have a very high disgusting reflex
you tend to be more conservative
and so to to to be like the
the pillar of liberal thought
is i should not be mad at you about for
something that you have nothing to do
with like you did not choose you're like
born
with that uh
and so most of the time people think of
that as gender
race sexual orientation like something
heritable you're like oh i should not be
upset at you about obviously you know
like uh
the fact that um you're born uh you know
with a particular trait
but then if you map political ideology
as being related
to heritable traits that you also have
no control over then all of a sudden
you're like wait a minute i can't get
mad at you for voting for trump either
because
that's something that's interesting i
haven't thought about like that
if you are listening to this you like
podcasts and you're thinking
what podcast is going to entertain me
but also give me some
actual knowledge i can use and onepad
podcast we recommend
hardly that does just that as a jordan
harbinger show
on apple podcast spotify wherever you
listen to podcasts wherever you got this
one
jordan's a really smart guy himself but
he brings on
experts and technicians who do
incredible things from frankly talking
people out of their money
[Laughter]
to safe cracking to spy craft
he's a bit of a guy so he kind of talks
to people that
you know you'd be interested in hearing
from
um who've done some james bond type
stuff so if you are
intrigued by how to bring some james
bond into your life
go to the jordan harbinger show we enjoy
the show think you will too
that's h-a-r-b as in boy
i-n-g-e-r on apple podcast spotify or
wherever you listen to podcasts
[Applause]
uh earlier matt you said something about
how you understand why people voted for
trump here's like the single biggest
thing that i
uh i have family members voted for trump
like you know i do not think trump
voters are
bad people uh
and one of the reasons why i think a lot
of people voted for trump
is they looked up and said government's
not working
you know we need something different uh
this person's gonna shake things up
and i do not find that to be an
irrational or unreasonable
sentiment you know you can look up and
legitimately say i do not think dc is
working for
the people for for me and the rest of it
i agree trump was the wrong guy
and you know he's um as or more corrupt
um but but one of the problems that i'm
seeing
is that that institutional mistrust is
rising across all groups
but the institutional mistrust is higher
among republicans and independents than
it is democrats whereas democrats are
still like no government
works government works we can just make
it work and then the rest of america is
completely losing confidence in that
we're like is this really working
and trump capitalized on that um and so
this to me is one of the big
challenges that we have to have
democrats embrace which is like look
if you're going to argue for government
we really have to get it working for
people at a much higher level
like not in just in a talking point
level but in like i'm actually making a
difference in your life level
that in a way that you can feel and
trust and will actually
change your mindset or attitude around
it it's one reason why i was for
universal basic income so strongly is
because that we could do and you would
feel it
yeah and i think that's important but i
will say this
you can you can give people changes in
their lives and if you
don't do it in a way this reflects the
value in them as humans it won't work so
let's use obamacare
obamacare is extremely popular in
kentucky
so long as you don't call it obamacare
you have to call it the aca
because in kentucky we got it through
our governor at the time
sort of accepted the medicaid expansion
when no other
uh when no other states like ours did
and now it's very popular but people
don't really give
credit to obama for it because they
don't give credit to democrats for it
because they're still stuck on this idea
that democrats somehow don't think
we're equal to them and i want to go
back what you said a minute ago about
traits because i think a lot of it is
traits i think a lot of people in rural
areas believe
and i'm not saying this is fair but i
understand why they believe it
that liberals are too judgmental just in
general about things
that like everyone has to be perfect to
liberals and if you're not they'll yell
at you all the time
and i'll give you an example that just
happened around around here in kentucky
there was a person who was a
sort of a social media figure that
everyone in kentucky knew which is weird
but they did
he had a pseudonym and he passed away
and when he passed away
you know i knew him he said a lot of
things when he was alive i wish he
hadn't said
he he was he was not perfect but i said
i'm very sorry to hear he died prayers
to his family
you know just the things you say as a
human being i got
shouted down by liberals all over the
country
like democratic advisors who said see
this is why you couldn't have had him as
the senate candidate
he's giving you know rest in peace
wishes to a person who said
bad things well i didn't like that he
said bad things
i wish he hadn't but he died and he had
two
children and a wife actually three
children and a wife
and if you can't show humanity at that
moment
then all these people just look at that
and go
he's got three daughters you can't say
rest in peace when he has
three daughters without getting screamed
at
i think a lot of folks in rural areas
just feel like
that they're constantly judged and it
becomes like it becomes very difficult
for them
to accept the other things that
democrats try to do that are
very positive for them and i i wish we
could again this goes back to my
christianity
we're all sinners no one is perfect
everyone makes mistakes now some
mistakes are worse than others but
none of us are perfect human beings
let's have
grace let's forgive people let's let
people redeem
themselves and i think we're bad at that
as liberals especially in recent years
and i wish we could get past that
the word i've used matt is patronizing
there's something patronizing about a
lot of the democratic party
and it's very alienating and we should
very much stop it if we can
there are two things that have made it
much much worse in recent years and
that's the polarization of media and
then social media
because now in social media you you end
up with very very
negative uh sentiments that get
amplified very quickly
and it's it's bad for all of us
um it's tearing us apart it's making it
impossible for us to come together
on some of the big solutions um but i
agree with you we have to deliver value
and we have to deliver
value to to people in a way that they'll
appreciate and
like and understand uh it is funny that
names matter
a great deal where if you called it
obamacare people would dislike it and
then you called it something else what
did they end up calling the affordable
care act it sounds like that
that one's okay they called it kentucky
connect
they call it the the governor at the
time who was who was the current
governor's dad steve beshear called it
kentucky connect
and people if you ask people today do
you like kentucky connect they'll say
yes
and then you can say do you like
obamacare and they'll say no because
they think they're two different things
because the folks that ran kentucky knew
we need to market this in a way people
will sign up for it
and in order to do that we have to make
them think they're signing up for a
kentucky
thing but let me say this too i don't
want people listening to this just think
well
matt why we say all these criticisms of
democrat well why aren't you just a
republican
in terms of ideas i think the ideas of
the democrats i don't think that at all
yeah i mean i've been i've been right
here with you uh you know and i think
everyone knows
like so go ahead sorry but like i i
think everything we just said is like
said with love and you know like uh
and brotherhood in terms of ideas i
think the democrats are in the right
place on most issues
not all but most and that's what i care
about is ideas but the reality is
politics is about people and i come at
this as a radio show host
you i cannot get 75 of my audience as
trump voters
i can't get them to listen to me if they
think i am
patronizing all that stuff i mean my
book got to the new york times
bestseller list
and and basically was bought primarily
by kentuckians
and honestly primarily a lot by
conservative kentuckians
who bought a book against mitch
mcconnell because they wanted to hear
what i had to say
about the state and politics
and we can do that in other places with
other candidates but there needs to be a
lesson i mean
after trump won there was all this talk
well how do we reach trump voters and i
would read all of that and it was all
just garbage it was nonsense and i like
jd vance as a person he's a nice guy but
they read hillbilly elegy and they
thought they were all
experts and i and it was like look
you asked me a little while ago how do
we fix this bring more people into the
conversation
look at the places where you want to
have success and where you've lost
because here's the thing about kentucky
we are
the reason trump won wisconsin michigan
and pennsylvania
those states the parts that he won are
just like kentucky
the only difference between those states
and kentucky is we don't have
philadelphia
milwaukee detroit to offset it but the
rural parts of michigan wisconsin and
pennsylvania
are just like in ohio are just like
kentucky
and if you want to know why trump won
all those places
look at kentucky because it's it's the
same
issues that were problems here were
problems there
and whether we win in 2020 or not and i
think we will
it'll be even if we pick up texas in
georgia down the road if we lose
michigan wisconsin and pennsylvania
it's still going to be hard for us those
are states that we have to keep winning
and to do that you've got to find a way
to reach the people i'm talking about
people should be calling you non-stop
matt because i think what you have to
offer is so
crucial uh and we can fight for a lot of
the same policies
and ideas and just frame them in ways
that people find
more interesting and appealing well you
did that i mean let's be honest you did
that
right now you came out in a campaign and
you talked about universal basic income
and when i first heard about that
i thought boy that's ridiculous and then
i went and heard you speak
and i went well you know what that makes
sense and then
six months later the whole country
agreed to it and nobody dissented now
they did it temporarily
but the idea of it was exactly the same
and i remember thinking
if everybody just gone to perry iowa
when i did and heard andrew talk
they would have seen that that's not a
crazy idea
you're a perfect example you took a
policy that on its face even i would
have been like
come on and you explained it in a way
that made people go
well now wait a minute and i think there
has to be a lot more of that
in order for us to compete as well as
the stuff i'm talking about
and we were not afraid to name it the
freedom dividend you know what i mean
like
like that that's why it's like because
we tested a bunch of names
and it turns out that so progressives
and liberals
liked it at a certain level no matter
what we called it we called it social
security for all
prosperity dividend opportunity dividend
and approval ratings were more or less
constant
uh people who are more conservative did
not like it
until we called it the freedom dividend
then all of a sudden the approval shot
up
then call it the freedom dividend don't
don't not call it that because you
somehow don't like the word freedom
call it freedom what do i care it's
still the same twelve hundred dollars
like that's that's that's what you do
you said something a minute ago that i
meant i meant to bring up when you said
it
but you were talking about the
importance of family you're talking
about small towns people won't get
married and have children
etc in small towns like in rep
in in rural places family is huge
and like it's not bad for us as
democrats to say you know what
two parent households that have a kid
that's good like it's not a bad
thing like that doesn't it doesn't make
it awful
but that's republicans talk about that
democrats shy away from it
why i don't understand why why i mean
that there is there is very clear
compelling data that
two parent households having a kid you
end up with
better chances of certain positive
outcomes so if you're
uh a society you look up and say okay
like we should probably encourage that
because by the numbers that's like a
a better shot at some things we like um
so democrats shying away from that
is counterproductive in my mind like who
does not have a family who does not care
about family
you know probably zero of us i mean we
all came from somewhere
so these are things that i agree with
you that um
democrats have sort of talked themselves
out of talking about
family faith values that we can all
agree on
loyalty authority you know one thing
that i'll share with you it's like
uh this is this may be kind of
small but you know that that song like
uh i'm proud to be
an american cause at least i know i'm
free
yeah so so i you know like the rnc they
play that song and i tweeted i was like
oh i like this song and then people were
like oh they ruined it for me and
whatnot and like republicans do
something very
um very fundamental that democrats need
to contest them on
which is that they claim uh they claim
the word america they claim the american
flag they like
do all this stuff and then democrats
sometimes look up and are like oh
like uh you know you you can't um bust
out like the
the flat out patriot patriotic language
or
uh i mean it's like of course we should
you know it's like what are you gonna do
you know it's our country it's like a
song you're talking about the listeners
to my show will
will laugh that you said that because i
joke about how i don't like that song
because but when i was a kid when i was
a kid they played that song
andrew every morning after we did the
pledge of allegiance at school every
morning
they played that song and that was ever
like there are tons of places in
kentucky that listen to that i'm proud
to be an american
every morning as as as in school
i think sometimes not always but i think
sometimes democrats are scared to look
patriotic because it almost seems
lame to be patriotic like waving a flag
is like
well i think there are problems with
america so if i wave a flag i act like
it's perfect no you don't
you're just happy like you're there's
nothing wrong with being proud
to be an american or proud to be a
christian or proud to be jewish or
muslim or whatever
but i i do think that like there are
parts of this that we've run away from
so when you go back to the first
question
how do you talk to these people you have
to tell them that their lives
have value and that their opinions have
value
even if you disagree with it abortion is
i don't talk about abortion ever but
i will say if you're pro-life
i understand like it doesn't make you a
bad human being it doesn't mean you want
to
enslave women and make it just means you
may look at this differently
than the pro-choice people look at it
and i wish
we could do that more on issues because
if we did
i think we'd have a whole lot better
chance of connecting with people
who then we've got to win over at the
end of the day you can be self-righteous
all you want
if we don't get 50.01 of the vote who
cares
like i mean how self-righteous how'd
that work out for you
yeah we need to get our 51 plus or 50.1
plus but then if we're gonna solve some
of these problems we need to
get a bigger consensus than that and
even the people who disagree with us
they have to know that
we care about them we value them we
listen to them so that we can
come together and and say okay
uh don't agree on this or that but
here's the direction we're gonna go
and then people will still be able to
live together uh
and hopefully prosper together i mean it
seems like a very
very distant ambition now for us to
prosper and flourish
but we we still have a chance at it you
know i should know this
man but are you a parent yourself no i'm
uh
i'm not i haven't gotten there yet in
life but
but one day oh well i mean you strike me
as a
very eminent um eminent bachelor then
i have a girlfriend i have a girlfriend
she's actually a tv producer
in uh in new york and a wonderful
wonderful woman
but i so so yes i but i am not a parent
yet but i agree with you
in terms of you building a consensus
i'll tell you what's interesting about
joe biden to me a lot of liberals still
can't believe joe biden's the nominee
i'll be honest with you andrew i always
thought he was going to win i even
thought he was going to win when he lost
iowa and new hampshire because
people forget about just the folks not
on social media
and they forget apparent in democratic
primaries about african-americans they
get forgotten
in the early democratic primary states
but
read polls that come out where they talk
about trades
and look how high joe biden always
scores in
cares about people like me he doesn't
score high in a lot of stuff
but even with republicans he will score
surprisingly high
and cares about people like me and i
think the reason that joe biden
ended up winning the primary he's going
to win the general election i think
and i think that republicans don't hate
him as much as they have other
candidates
is they genuinely believe most people
that he cares about them
and that is a very effective trait for
politics
i agree on all fronts and i am thrilled
to see what the future holds for you
matt
i think you are uh just what the party
needs that's what kentucky needs just
what the country
needs people should be going to much
more than
they are hopefully this conversation
helps
push the democratic party in a
particular direction
and hope at some point hopefully they
manage to talk you into running
because you would have been a really
really fun awesome
um candidate against mitch certainly if
you've gone through the primary
uh congressional candidate last cycle
i'm sure they'll stay after you
but if you do run you'll have my support
because i would love to see you
making your case in kentucky uh and then
going all the way to dc and talking
sense to more people there
so thank you and looking forward to
seeing what the future holds and thank
you and when this pandemic
ends or slows down i want you i i i want
you to come to kentucky
and and do a speech or something and let
me kind of show you around because i do
think your message
plays here in a way i think people
thought of you as a person that would
play in cities i think your strength is
going to be in small towns
and i hope you will i hope you'll get do
some of that when when things open up a
little bit
i would love that yeah let's make it
happen post pandemic it'll be one more
thing to look forward to
yeah thank you very much thank you for
listening in i hope you enjoyed this
conversation
if you did please do subscribe to yang
speaks and click on notifications so we
can let you know every time we have a
new episode